I'LL.
LIKE TO CALL THE COMMITTEE TO TO
ORDER.
AND ALSO LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
NEW MEMBERS OR NEW BY SHEER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID AND ALSO --
NEW MEMBERS --
DOCTOR CHOI JUST JOINING US.
AND AND DEFINITELY WILL COME THE
TO RETURNING MEMBERS AND AND AND
THE SYRIAN AND CHEWING.
AND TODAY WE HAVE ACTUALLY THREE
ITEMS.
IN THE ALL LOVE TO FIRST ASK
THREE THE SECRETARY TO TAKE THE
ROLE.
KANSEN CHU.
KANSEN CHU HERE HE HERE.
HERE DAVID CHIU HERE WHICH YOU
CARE.
SHOWING HERE [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN IN THIS NEWS VOTE
SESSION WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
RULES TO ADOPT.
AND CAN I ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
OKAY WOULD DO HOW --
MOTION AND SECONDS WITHIN
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL KANSEN CHU.
JAKE [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE FIVE AND DAVID CHIU.
ON SHOWING HIGH NINE FRIEDMAN.
IN ORDER TO HAVE.
AREA --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN WOULD HELP TO BILLS ON A
MISTER GLORIA.
AND CAN --
MAKERS WILL AS COAL AUTHOR ALL
BE PRESENTING FOR MR GLORIA.
AND ALSO A BILL --
HR.
THIRTEEN OF THIS MEETING BILLS
MY BILL SO --
ASTRI OF A BY SHARE TO TAKE OVER.
AND PERCENT THE TO BILL I
PROMISE YOU REAL QUICK
[inaudible] FIFTY FIVE CAN I
START WITH THE AC ARE.
TWENTY FIVE NOR WILL ALREADY HOW
THE OF MOTION [inaudible]
NAY.
AND THE SECOND ALL RIGHT.
YEAH I'M.
IS MICHAEL.
I WANT TO OWN A GREAT PROUD TO
PRESENT A C. R..
THE FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
AND WHICH WERE RECOGNIZED MARCH.
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AS TO
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTION AND PARK
DAY.
AND ALSO COMMEMORATE THE
FIFTEENTH ANNIVERSARY OF TO
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTION AND PARK
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY HOME TO
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
ATTRACTIONS.
USER TRACTORS AND PARKS HAVE
BEING A VITAL PART OF CALIFORNIA
CULTURE AND AN ECONOMY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONG.
VISITORS TO OUR STATE SPEND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
DOES REVENUE HELP TO SUPPORT
OVER ONE MILLION JOBS AND
GENERATED ROUGHLY TEN POINT
NINETY BILLING IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES TO SUPPORT A VITAL
PUBLIC SERVICES.
ACR TWENTY FIVE WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
THE IMPORTANCE ROLE ATTRACTIONS
AND PARKS PLATES AND CALIFORNIA
PAST.
PRESENT AND FUTURE THERE'S
RESOLUTION WILL ALSO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE CONTRIBUTION TO
HAVE THREE MAY TWO CALIFORNIA
TOURISM INDUSTRY.
BY THE CALIFORNIA ATTRACTION AND
PARK ASSOCIATION.
THE ACR IS SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA ON THE TRACTION AND
PARK ASSOCIATION AND HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION.
IS ERIN.
CARREIRO.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GLORY
AND DAILY FOR CARRYING IT.
AGAIN ERIN CAREER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRACTION AND
PARKS ASSOCIATION I PROMISED TO
KEEP MY TESTIMONY VERY BRIEF --
CALIFORNIA'S UNDENIABLY THE
BIRTH PLACE OF THE AMUSEMENT
PARK INDUSTRY FROM HUMBLE
BEGINNINGSAND BOYS AND VERY
FIELDS OF ORANGE GROVES.
OF THE INDUSTRY HAS GROWN
CONSIDERABLY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU MENTIONED THERE ARE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ATTRACTIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
DRAWING NINETY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION VISITORS EACH YEAR.
AND SERVING AS A DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND CALIFORNIA'S VIBRANT
TOURISM INDUSTRY.
THESE PARKS ARE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE STATE AND
LOCAL ECONOMIES THROUGH THROUGH
THE TAXES THEY PAY.
THEIR REVENUE IMPACT AND THE
NEARLY.
BUT THEY ARE SO MUCH MORE THAN
JUST AN ECONOMIC ENGINE.
CALIFORNIA'S ATTRACTIONS AND
PARKS ALSO GIVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND PARTICIPATE IN A WIDE RANGE
OF CHARITABLE PROGRAMS AND THEY
ALSO PROVIDE A DREAM LIKE THEN
YOU FOR FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS.
YOUNG AND OLD ALIKE TO FORGET
THEIR CARES FOR A LITTLE BIT.
FEED THEIR IMAGINATIONS AND
NURTURE THEIR SPIRIT AND TO
CREATE LASTING MEMORIES THEY ARE
THICK THREAD IN THE FABRIC OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT ACR.
TWENTY FIVE WITH THAT --
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTION FOR A
WITNESSES. FIVE HEARING NONE OF
DOCTOR CHOI.
YEAH ALREADY --
MAYBE MOTIONS MADE THEM THE
SECOND IT THE SO I'LL LET ME --
MAKE A COMMENT AND THEN ALSO --
OR YOU HAVE A QUESTION THAT I
HAVE -- THIS
IS -- VERY --
I THINK --
APPROPRIATE TO INTRODUCING INTO
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
UNDERSTANDING NOW SERVING ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE FIRST
TIME I'M LEARNING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA SO.
ATTRACTIONS AND THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
DIFFERENT --
ATTRACTIONS SO AND THEN THE 30%
OFF --
AMUSEMENT PARK --
THE ATTENDANCE OF VISIT. TO
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN SO --
AT THE MANY OF THE FACTORS SO WE
CANNOT TALK ABOUT THE BUT THAT
TO ME IS SO --
WHAT I?
READ IS SO TWELVE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO ACT WHAT IN
DIRECTOR.
OF COMMUNITY --
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT US TO HUGE.
YET AND THEN --
ONE POINT FIVE TAX REVENUES TO
THIS THE STATE TO REVENUE WITH
US A HUGE.
SO WHAT THIS IS A VERY --
IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY --
SO I DON'T KNOW --
ANYONE CAN --
AND SIR --
WHAT KIND OF PROMOTIONS SO?
THAT THE DESIGN AN ASSET SUB AND
WE HAVE A NORMAL CALIFORNIA --
TO PROMOTE EVEN FOR THE TO
ATTRACT MORE PEOPLE --
WHAT BUDGET IS TO ALLOCATED DOT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET?
AND WHAT THAT DOES --
ENOUGH FOR WHAT THE WE CAN DO
MORE A START ECCENTRIC OF RECORD
YOU KNOW BUDGET WILL CALL COVER
CALIFORNIA.
IN WHICH ONE ON TROUBLING WITHIN
OUR MOM THIS IS CALIFORNIA. TO
TO DO A PROMOTE GOOD TO TOUR
SOME BUSINESS --
IF AS IS THAT ENOUGH ON NO.
NO WILL DEFINITELY WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE MORE MONEY TO TILL WE CAN
DO MORE AGGRESSIVE --
PROMOTION BUT THERE ARE SOME
BUDGET ALLOCATED FOR WOULD YOU
HAPPEN TO KNOW THE AMOUNT YOU
KNOW I I DON'T ON TOP OF MY HEAD.
ERIN I DON'T KNOW OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD EITHER BUT I'M HAPPY TO
FIND OUT AND GET BACK TO YOU.
BUT WE ARE ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY AND WE WORK
WITH IS A CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION TO
TRY.
TO YOU KNOW AS YOU SAID PROMOTE
THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT IS SUCH
A SUCH AN INCREDIBLE BOON TO THE
STATE [inaudible]
YEAH THIS.
A COMMITTEE THAT I AM NEWLY
ASSIGNED THE AS THE ASSEMBLY --
COMEDIA ART ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM.
INTERNET THE MEDIA WILL.
THE MMHM --
TO FIFTY SIX FORM.
SO ALL.
VERY INTERESTING BUT THIS I CAN
BE OF VERY IMPACT FOR REVENUE
SOURCES.
POTENTIALLY SO I THINK THAT THIS
IN THE ENOUGH ONE NOT THE OF FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY OWN CITY THAT I
COME FROM A SEATED IRVINE --
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
AWAY ON A WE ARE BUILDING.
THE LARGEST A PUBLIC PARKER --
OF THE COUNTRY --
IS CALLED ORANGE COUNTY QUA
PARKER INTO SPORTS SPARKLE LOAN
IS A HUNDRED SIXTY ACRES SO IS
OUR COMPLETE DATA AND THAT THAT
WILL ATTRACT ALL KINDS OF A
SPORTS ACTIVITIES SUCH.
AS AND AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
SO -- THAT
THE CULTURE TAURUS SELF WE ARE
TRYING TO BE INTO --
IN THE ADD.
TO AND ALL FOUR HUNDRED FEET UP
IT IS A POTENTIAL RIGHT NOW ONE
OF THE NOT TOURISTS --
ATTRACTION --
WHEN THEY COME TO OUR A CITIZEN
IN ANAHEIM --
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF SOUTH OF WHY
YOU KNOW THEY CAN VISIT THAT THE
WI PARKER STONE.
WE HAVE A POTENTIAL IN DAY --
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT.
A MAN IT TEARS AT THAT WE
DEVELOP A NEED TO BE PROMOTED.
THAT DEFINITELY YOU KNOW --
LIKE TO CONNECT YOU WITH A VISIT
CALIFORNIA --
MAYBE PUT DRIVE PARK PARTICULAR
PARKING AND AND AND A MAP.
WELL I THINK YOU'VE GOT THE CHOI
AND I THINK YOU WITNESSES --
WITHOUT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS A
COMMENT --
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL FOR
THIS BILL.
SINCE HERE ARE [inaudible]
I HI.
DAVID CHIU.
AREN'T CHOI AYE [inaudible]
I COM WATER THAT.
IS THERE.
HI IS THERE ANY.
ACR TWENTY FIVE TO BE ADOPTED
AND SENT TO THIRD READING.
THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT ITEM IS
THE H. R. THIRTEEN TO TERMINAL
YOU PRESENT ON THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
AND I'M HAPPY TO UP PRETEND HR
THIRTEEN CULTURE DECLARED THE
FIRST WEDNESDAY IN FEBRUARY.
S. CALL UPON YOUR OF GIRLS AND
WOMEN'S SPORTS DAY A DIFFERENT
SPORT SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE FLOOR WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MEMBER.
OF THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
ON H. R..
THIRTEEN HR THIRTEEN TO BE
ADOPTED AND SENT TO THIRD
READING KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
KANSEN CHU ONLINE DEEP BY. NINE
DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI AYE
[inaudible] NINE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
MARGARITA.
HIS AREA AND IS THERE IN HIGH.
IN THE HR THIRTEEN TO BE ADOPTED
AND SENT TO THIRD READING.
OF IS THE CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE YOUR FEEDBACK.
THANK OF WORKING WITH A WHOLE
LIFTING A FIREWALL WALL THE ROLE
OF THE FEDERAL OPEN [inaudible]
A WELL.
THIS IS
[inaudible]
YOU CAN.
HI HOW MUCH [inaudible]
I AC ARE TWENTY FIVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
HI I'M MARGARET OF ONLINE.
HR THIRTEEN COM LOCKER DATA
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MA'AM --
THE PROBLEM OUR REGION WE WE
HAVE.
WE HAVE YOUR IN.
VERY MUCH CALIFORNIA